this is the everything drone dji mini 3
pro rc controller we're going to fly
here first impression zach you excited
yeah you know kazaki flies a lot of
drones here on geek culture i fly a
little bit as well but fpv at home and
at the mavic 2
you know zacky you've had some fun with
your drones before in the past haven't
you oh yeah a lot of near misses and
some hits yeah some real bad hits we'll
show you that later on the video but
anyway we're gonna test this bad boy out
uh big thanks to dji singapore we only
got one battery so this will be a
relatively short video but then we'll do
a first impressions and you're gonna be
seeing some more footage over the coming
weeks in various different videos so
that let's test out
the mini three pro
one of the big things on this is the
course the updated sensors on this so
you have sensors in the front in the
back and below
obstacle deterrence much needed for any
drone drones that do not have it
you've got to be really good at your
flying because otherwise you're gonna
hit something also you got the sd card
in the back hero which is a little bit
tough to lock that card in
and i've tried it multiple times i
actually had to take another card and
kind of really kind of keep lock it in
there again this is the demo unit so it
might be a bit of an issue with that
maybe yours will be better but just keep
that in mind usbc charging on this so if
you want to charge the drone you can do
that and this battery is ultra light i
mean this drone only weighs 249 grams
with this battery about 34 minutes of
flight time say realistically around 30
minutes thereabouts depending on how you
fly it if you get the larger capacity
battery will increase the weight then
you have to register your drone
depending on what country you're in so
do keep that in mind and uh yeah i got a
4k60 camera on this you do decently like
and all that great stuff you've got 1080
at 120.
so it's pretty much part and parcel with
a lot of drones out there from dgi but
it comes in a very compact lightweight
body so now that's enough about the
specs let's fly this bad boy let's fly
zacky fly anyway before we kick things
off here's a message from our sponsor
logitech here at geek culture we love
our keyboards especially with the all
new logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
[Music]
all right
zachy and i are trying to get the dji
mini 3 pro to work
how do we do that
special feature thing special feature
thingy that is a new feature from dji
special feature thingy
works well the dji mini 3 pro is going
to track us right there see that right
there you can see in the sun can't you
no yeah you can you can see right there
look at that
what's up joni look at that look at that
drone right there look at that drone
right there yes the drone is taking off
oh don't hit the building don't hit
the building exactly back
we're in singapore i want to stay in
singapore don't get me in trouble zacky
it's only 249 grams we should be okay
but
enough it goes
right up into the sunset
look at that look at that look at that
wow
look at that cinema mode right there
look at that
i mean relatively short because we only
have one battery we didn't get the fly
more package for this review uh dji
singapore only sent us the drone the rc2
controller and of course one battery
highly recommend you always get the fly
more package always get it no matter
what it's a fewer hundred or more bucks
but it's so much more worth it
especially with what you get this
controller is absolutely badass it's a
must forget using your phone right it's
great right that's great i mean
the brightness on the display you can
see in a bright daylight no problem at
all it is so much better to use
here's the thing about this drone
exactly show this drone quick see this
there's nothing to hold the propellers
in place see there's nothing to hold
nothing yeah like you know i think the
air tourist has a little bit of a bra to
it right the rubber strap bra kind of a
thing you would think that they would do
it for this one because it just flops
around and it's not good you don't want
to you don't want floppy propeller wings
you want them to be stable especially
when you put into a bag and also the
cover if you put on this camera is the
hardest thing i've ever had to put on to
any drone it takes like five minutes to
put on
this camera
keeps wanting to tilt down and go on an
odd angle now you can't put that in with
this cover here it's got to be exact so
you got to put your thumb in there hope
for the best that it stays
who designed this cover they don't get a
promotion this year no bonus but besides
that drone is super stable easy to fly
it's quiet the controller is awesome
great image quality is going to see
throughout this review and yeah that's
our first impression full review coming
very soon but i mean you've already seen
a lot of videos on it but i will tell
you this this is probably gonna be one
of the most fun drones to use right zach
i mean and it's only a few hundred bucks
less than the fpv but it's a lot less to
carry with you at the same time it's
gonna cover most the shots that you need
and especially if you're new to flying
drones but you want something that's got
some obstacle detection great 4k video
photography portrait mode
portrait mode baby instagram stories ig
reels all that stuff it's in this you
can do it with this anyway with that
guys follow us on facebook subscribe to
the channel
like our videos follow follow up follow
us on instagram as well what's your
zacky it because he's an i.t guy
b tanelli and uh with that we'll catch
you next video take care
[Music]